hunts but now increasingly says no I
need my guns for self-defense and so
just one of the cake cases that I think
I think about yeah that maybe goes
beyond what you could do in your book is
is the incident out at at the Malheur
National Wildlife Refuge about a year
ago and so you have these these guys who
are angry and fearful they hate the
Bureau of Land Management they believe
that they really own this land and so
they take over this federal facility
heavily armed and you know and
eventually the the you know they're
they're they're overrun they're
apprehended to arrest it but within a
year they are acquitted yep
you know and and and it happens not in
Malheur County or Jefferson County or
part Harney County out there in rural
Oregon but in Portland Oregon which is
which is which is really weird so I just
wonder if you have reflections about
whether there's a kind of nuance to the
generalization about the uniquely
American quality of some of these things
by looking at you know the urban rural
split that's a great question I don't
know I I really don't I mean I feel like
in my book I've got kind of a mix of
examples different case cases and I'm
also more recently a report came out on
Chicago like I think about Chicago in
particulars a really interesting case um
Illinois was the last state to grant its
citizens concealed carry permits it was
the last of the 50 so now in all 50
states you can have a concealed carry
permit or permit less carry if you're in
one of the 12 states that has
constitutional carry but it's gun
violence in Chicago in in in particular
areas is really intractable problem when
you look at the sort of cauldron of
underserved communities withdrawal of
social safety net of various forms gang
violence
Masen hyper incarceration racialized
incarceration
and police violence it's a really
intractable problem and so yes there is
a real difference and the only time I
really spend on that difference between
the rural versus the urban is in the
chapter where I'm looking at
african-american resistance armed
resistance and and it and and the
interesting thing that I find is that we
talked about the Black Panther Party but
the precursors were were rural the the
first black civil rights organizations
to be armed and stand up to white
supremacy with weapons all according to
the law happen in the rural South so
like Monroe North Carolina and different
rural areas in Mississippi and Alabama
and and and yet we don't hear about
those in our history books as much as we
do about the Black Panther Party which
gets demonized as being anti white or
violent so yeah and in terms of
quote-unquote riots the language of
riots that's mostly an urban phenomenon
as well but I don't really know what to
say then about the sort of difference
there between the the translation from
rural to urban in terms of armed
citizenship can you say with did the
trial occur in Portland so I'm actually
serious about the jury pool so that
because the actual case develops in
febrile lands and an area one with
characterizes were all but a jury a jury
is found and and seeded in Portland that
is persuaded by the self defense
argument given so it would I mean that
seems to me to suggest the rural-urban
distinction might not even hold I want
to know more about the demographics I
suppose of the jury and how they were
selected but in some ways it doesn't
even really matter like what I find is
that it doesn't like often the
demographics of the jury don't matter as
much as the prevailing ideologies
what's reasonable so like in Zimmerman's
trial and in in many other trials it
doesn't matter you can have people of
color in the jury who still think that
it's reasonable for particular social
actors to stand their ground or to be
fearful in a particular moment so in a
way I'm not all that surprised but it is
it is sort of interesting that in the
city they would see this as a reasonable
set of behaviors and certainly those
folks end up becoming kind of lionized
they become like the action heroes of
do-it-yourself security citizenship for
for many people who believe that that
should be alright
good question so on the topic of juries
I was actually wondering if you thought
about the relationship between all of
this and the rise of plea bargaining in
the United States so obviously like the
cases that get the most news coverage of
juries and they're all terrible but I
kind of been thinking isn't it
incredibly dangerous to have defense
counsel on you alluded to this with Kai
Peterson's case that is like operating
based on their own projections of this
bad white jury like how how have how did
you find that that impacts cases
especially with domestic violence cases
and I honestly this is something I'm not
a legal scholar so I'm learning as I go
so maybe we can talk about this later
because I'd love to hear more of your
insights on it but a lot of domestic
violence survivors will plead down
because they're instructed that it's the
best way to get out of serving more
prison time so what happens is that
influences the shape of our archive it
influences the way in which we see these
cases as stand-your-ground cases or as
cases of
of something else whether it's
justifiable homicide or excusable or you
know just straight on criminal homicide
so yeah people who recognize that in the
jury's eyes they are less likely to be
perceived as reasonable and their claims
of fear will often plead down or be
instructed to do so so again it comes
back to class and resources and whether
you have the money to hire a great
defense attorney has a lot to do with it
so it's yet another vector of inequality
that influences who's going to end up
behind bars for basically exercising
their right to defend themselves
so you've touched on police brutality a
little bit and I'm curious about looking
at the historical context you've
outlined in the idea of property in the
this historical definition and how it
kind of gets amplified when a blue
uniform is put on and you can talk talk
about that in terms of something like
the Stanford Prison Experiment but you
can also look at it in terms of the idea
of property changing of the thing you
need to protect in a uniform is the
public safety and so it becomes this
massive thing that one person is
protecting and I'm curious how what you
think about that a lot of different
layers to that question so if I
understand correctly one one is how
policing becomes focused around public
safety which is often very much code for
protecting property I mean often when we
see oh there's a riot happening in
Ferguson it's the major transgressions
that call out law enforcement are when
people you know destroy private property
whether it's automobiles or stores or
whatever that these are seen as
transgressions against public safety
rather than trust transgressions on
public safety so absolutely there is
sort of a call to protect private
property for sure
another thing with law enforcement or
just what I found historically I found a
lot of really troubling things
historically actually but but one of
them was that for law enforcement it's a
much lower bar in a case of a police
shooting especially of an unarmed
citizen it's a much lower bar for the
police to be exonerated based on
reasonable fear and self defense so when
a law enforcement a member of law
enforcement claims self-defense after
shooting an unarmed civilian it's easier
for them to get exonerated and it has
been for a very very long time
and this has a long genealogy there's
also a lot of disturbing stuff I found
about post-reconstruction policing in
the South that police forces in southern
states proliferated in the wake of Black
Liberation in response to what was
perceived as the threat to public safety
of black freedom itself so policing
emerges in certain southern
jurisdictions in response to that so
none of that is really surprising to me
except the extent to which now we have
recording devices readily at our
disposal we can record these instances
of police violence and still justice as
elusive there was a case just a day and
a half ago in I want to say California
somewhere in California where an
off-duty white police officer basically
was trying to hold on to this child this
13 year old
I think Latino boy and ended up in the
end pulling a gun on him and shooting
didn't kill anybody thank goodness
but the 13 year old boy and a 15 year
old friend who was trying to intervene
have our facing criminal charges the
police officer so far hasn't been
charged with anything but if you look at
this video it's shocking this is an
adult grown man brutalizing a small
child it continues and I I don't really
know what to say about it except yes
that is absolutely imbued with notions
of property and who has the right to own
that property and protect it I think the
reason the man was attacking the child
was because the child had had had been
on his property so it comes up again and
again and again I think that this I
would I I want I was home as soon as I
can we had a happy ending but I actually
think that that would be to turn away
from what I think is the urgent and
sobering and just such important
argument of your book and that in fact
history has many things to tell us
but our current moment and which bodies
can be safe which bodies can be targeted
for violence including lethal violence
and which cannot and it's not about a
happy ending it's about making better
futures together and so a dr. Caroline
light thank you for being in
conversation with me this evening you
will happily sign copy Superbook
actually and she will actually in the
service of selling books sign any book
that you buy here at my you butcher this
evening any book any of these books on
legal theory and evidence thank you so
much Caroline light and aunt Peregrine
thank you all for being here we also
have a book that and Pellegrini had
co-authored you can tell just by looking
and 20 other myths about LGBT life and
people though they're on sale this
evening and we thank you for being here
and hope to see you again soon and may
we have peaceful times thank you
[Applause]
book TV tapes hundreds of author
programs throughout the country all year
long here's a look at some of the events
we'll be covering this week on Monday
will be at East City bookshop in
Washington DC where former special
assistant to President George HW Bush
Doug Wead will discuss the 2016
presidential election on Tuesday at Ivy
book shop in Baltimore Pulitzer
prize-winning journalist will England
will recall President Woodrow Wilson's
pivot away from American isolationism
and the lead-up to World War one
Wednesday we head out west to Roman's
bookstore in Pasadena California where
science writer rod Pyle will report on
some of the lesser-known space missions
and on Thursday will be at book Smith
bookstore in Berkeley California where
historian and activist Rebecca Solnit
will examine changes occurring within
the feminist movement that's a look at
some of the program's book TV we'll be
covering this week many of these events
are open to the public look for them to
air in the near future on book TV on
c-span too
and who's this this is Henrietta Leavitt
who was looking at we're going to get to
these magnificent images who was looking
at images taken from South America
because the whole sky had to be covered
there was a second observatory built in
Peru to photograph the stars of the
southern hemisphere and she was looking
at images of the Magellanic Clouds and
she discovered a couple thousand
variable stars and made a fundamental
discovery about the pattern of variation
that the stars that took the longest
time to go through their cycles tended
to be the brightest stars and she
figured all of the stars she was looking
at were roughly the same distance away
so the ones that look bright a really
were brighter and that observation led
to the first usable yardstick for
measuring what we would call now
galactic distances and intergalactic
distances in space and her work enabled
the size of the Milky Way to be
determined I may be getting ahead of the
slides here but also to figure out the
Milky Way was not the only galaxy in the
universe that the universe in fact
consisted of multiple galaxies galaxies
so it would be fair to say that at that
time they weren't sure if the universe
was maybe just a few hundred thousand
light years across and maybe that was it
that was it or even the shape of the
universe like this led to us looking at
you know what geometry of globular
clusters and spiral galaxies and then to
place ourselves within that geometry you
can watch this and other programs online
at book tv.org
good morning I'm Kellie McCutcheon
president of the Georgia Public Policy
Foundation like to welcome everyone to
our February leadership breakfast most
importantly I'd like to welcome our
elected officials that are here today we
appreciate your service we have got a
great event lined up for you today on an
issue that's very near and dear to our
hearts and it's a key part of something
that we feel very strongly about is
economic opportunity and to introduce
our speaker I want to bring up our vice
president Bonita Dodd good morning I'm a
little shorter and closer to the mic so
I can I hope you can hear me a little
better I'd like to welcome dick
carpenter today but I want to tell you
first how much we have worked over the
years with the Institute for justice I
think their motto is we sue government
and that sounds pretty good to me but
dick is a Dickies co-author of bottle
necklace and don't miss your opportunity
to get a copy of this it is excellent
and shocking here bottleneck is gaming
the government for power and private
profit he's also director of strategic
research for the Institute for justice
where he works with staff and attorneys
to define implement and manage social
science research related to the
Institute's mission he's an experienced
researcher he is presented and published
on a variety of topics ranging from
education policy to the dynamics of
presidential elections so catch him
later to talk about that his work has
appeared in academic journals including
the economic development quarterly
economic affairs the forum Fordham
Fordham urban law journal international
journal of ethics education and urban
society urban studies regulation and
government governance and magazines
including regulation Hideout phi pi I'm
not from around here at Deltek happen
and the American School Board Journal
moreover his R is the results of his
research have been quoted in newspapers
such as the New York Times The
Washington Post and The Wall Street
Journal his research for Institute for
justice includes reports such as
discover cost the unintended
consequences of campaign finance reform
license to work private choice in public
programs how private institutions secure
social services for Georgians
designing cartels how industry insiders
cut out competition and victimizing the
vulnerable the demographics of eminent
domain abuse and if you know the
Institute for justice they've done some
excellent work that resulted in some of
the toughest eminent domain legislation
in Georgia so we thank you for that
before working with the Institute for
justice dr. carpenter was a school
teacher and principal he's a public
policy analyst and a faculty member at
the University of Colorado Colorado
Springs where he's currently a professor
he has a PhD from the University of
Colorado and despite what you might
think he does have some spare time in
his life and he tells me that he is a
classical classically trained musician
percussionist and a pilot and he
promises that he doesn't do them at the
same time so we'd like to welcome dr.
carpenter well good morning it's a
pleasure to be with you this morning to
talk about our book and chip since his
his regards as well he is in retirement
now in Utah so that would have been
quite a trip for him to come and so if
you know chip we just send his regards
this morning I want to begin by
introducing you to somebody from our
book and that is Kim powers bridges Kim
owns and operates bridges funeral home
in Tennessee but she's not from
Tennessee Kim is actually from Oklahoma
she started her first business there a
funeral business but she had to leave
Oklahoma when she ran afoul of the law
it turns out that Kim was engaged in the
very dangerous practice of selling
caskets without a funeral directors
license before that in the early 1980s
Kim was on the executive fast-track she
grew up in a family of hard-working
entrepreneurs she learned the
relationship between hard work and
success and after she left college she
enjoyed a lot of success in a number of
different businesses and eventually she
ended up at one of the nation's largest
funeral companies and there she sold
pre-need funeral services and she saw
this as a way to combine her drive in
business with her desire to help people
through her work and as before she was
very successful in that business but
after a few years she began to notice
that there was a need a niche to be
filled a classic entrepreneur and that
was she saw that in the funeral industry
the merchandise that was sold was marked
up a significant amount caskets for
instance would be marked up anywhere
from 250 to 600 percent so she began to
think how could I put together a
business model that would enable me to
sell the same merchandise but at a much
lower cost
so she eventually left this funeral
business she joined up with Dennis
Bridges who had left the same company
and they spent a year forming what
became memorial concepts online and as
the name implies their business plan was
to sell everything all of their
merchandise particularly caskets over
the internet and they would take
advantage of drop shipping from
manufacturers so they wouldn't have any
inventory on hand that enabled them to
keep their costs very low and then they
passed on those savings to the consumers
and they thought they had a winning
business plan and they did but they ran
into a problem and the problem was
Oklahoma State law says that if you want
to sell a casket to consumers in
Oklahoma and you're an oklahoma-based
company you must be licensed as a
funeral director and Kim was not now she
could have gone back to earn this
license but it would require her to go
to school for two years she would have
to complete an internship during which
time she would embalm 25 bodies then she
would have to have a brick and mortar
business in which she would have a
selection room a preparation room
a viewing room and she would have to
have inventory on hand
none of which they were interested in as
if it were not irrational enough to
require a funeral directors license to
sell a box because that's what a casket
is it's an empty box the law also
created a circumstance where an
oklahoma-based company had to be a
licensed funeral director to sell to
consumers in Oklahoma but companies
outside of the state who sold to
consumers in Oklahoma did not have to
have a funeral directors license so Kim
could have taken her business which was
essentially computer servers she could
have taken her servers and moved across
the state line to Kansas and there she
could have sold caskets to consumers in
Oklahoma all day long but she didn't
want to do that she wanted to stay in
Oklahoma she wanted to raise her family
in her hometown of Ponca City and she
thought the law was wrong and not only
wrong but injurious because it enabled
funeral directors to mark up their
merchandise and take advantage of people
who were at a difficult or vulnerable
time in their lives so she stayed in
Oklahoma and she fought the law well she
wasn't the only one who thought this law
was wrong some legislators did so as
well so beginning in 1999 they began
introducing a series of bills every year
to remove the licensing requirement for
casket sales Kim testified on behalf of
several of these bills and every year
they lost they lost for one reason and
one reason alone and that was the
license funeral directors the industry
would go to the legislature and they
would lobby aggressively to protect
their license and every year they
succeeded so today in Oklahoma if you
want to sell a casket and you are an
oklahoma-based company you must have a
funeral directors license what Kim and
the legislators ran into is what we call
in our book the bottleneck errs a bomb
maker somebody who advocates for the
creation or perpetuation
of a government regulation particularly
an occupational license to restrict the
free flow of workers into an occupation
in order to enjoy an economic benefit as
a result the bond liquors are evident
throughout the economy
we know that our doctors and our
attorneys have licenses then we
generally know that our barber has a
license or our cosmetologist has a
license but recent research that we
published indicates the occupations that
now require a license might surprise you
so if you want to be an auctioneer for
instance you have to be licensed or if
you want to be a sign language
interpreter or a locksmith or florist in
Louisiana or a crane operator or a
funeral attendant the list goes on and
on of occupations that for years were
never licensed but now are because of
the work of bond liquors for 25 years we
at the Institute for justice have fought
to reform occupational licensing we've
represented individuals who want nothing
more than to exercise their right to
earn an honest living
IJ is a law firm as you heard Bonita
described and we've represented people
for the past 25 26 years our very first
case was on the issue of occupational
licensing Inc and economic Liberty and
we have continued to litigate on behalf
of these individuals throughout this
time and what we've discovered in all of
this is that there is a myth about
occupational licensing and the myth is
this licenses are created at the request
of harmed consumers and citizens but the
truth is legislators create licenses at
the request of those in the industry to
be licensed at first blush it seems
absurd why would anyone ask for more
government intrusion into their business
but the answer to the question like so
many questions is to follow the money
those in the industry come to recognize
that a license creates a bottleneck it
excludes competitors it enables them to
artificially inflate prices and wages as
a result for their own benefit but the
push for licensure is more than just
about economic advantage when you hear
bottom liquors ask for a license their
language will often be something like we
also need this license to come to confer
to us a certain amount of status
recognition we want to be licensed
because we want to be like those other
occupations or professions that are
already licensed a certain recognition
that comes only with licensure so as a
result when a reform bill is introduced
in the legislature or when a license is
challenged in court the bottleneck codes
will mount a ferocious campaign in order
to protect their license and the funeral
industry is just one example in 25 years
we have yet to find a single example of
a license that is created by any means
or protected by any means other than the
bottleneck errs but yet this myth
persists these licenses exists for some
demonstrable reasons some need that's
out there when in fact that is not true
so we wrote the book in order to dispel
this myth but we also wrote the book
because we wanted to coin a new term we
wanted to create a word that would be
descriptive and useful and accessible
and perhaps most importantly pejorative
we wanted to have a word that could be
used to name and shame those who engage
in this activity or enable this activity
so with the word bottleneck errs we drew
on a well-known metaphorical bottleneck
something that restricts free flow or
free movement and we wanted to take
advantage of the negative Freight
associated with the word right so we're
familiar with a bottleneck in traffic
that we see even this morning and we're
familiar with the effect of that that is
the two-hour morning commute that comes
as a result of the bottleneck so we
wanted to take advantage of that
to the fullest extent possible so each
industry in our book from cosmetologist
stew dietitians and nutritionists have
exhibited classics special interest
behavior what we call bottle necking
behavior on behalf of their license and
those of you who have been active in the
legislature or elected officials
recognize this behavior instantly things
like coordinated letter-writing
campaigns to legislators or crowding out
legislative committee hearings or
industry day at the Capitol special
awards to legislators campaign
contributions are going to a committee
hearing and filling testimony full of
unsubstantiated facts and scary sounding
anecdotes for example your neighbor to
the South several years ago the
legislature considered whether to repeal
a licensing bill for interior designers
that bill received enormous attention
interior designers from Florida and even
from outside the state deluge the state
legislature hours of testimony during
which interior designers talked about
the importance of their license one of
them said that if you repeal this law it
will result in the deaths of 88,000
people per year now our book is somewhat
backward-looking in that we're examining
the creation and protection of licenses
throughout various different industries
but the bottom linking that we described
in the book is not an historical
artifact this is something that
continues today and there's no better
example than the American Music Therapy
Association and the certification board
for music therapists these two
organizations have mounted a nationwide
campaign to license music therapy and
when they make the request in the state
legislators their language is always the
same and it's the same as bottleneck
errs have used for decades
we need to protect public health and
safety from the unlicensed practice of
music therapy every bottom like you're
going back decades has said this same
thing through the advocacy efforts of a
regulatory affairs team and state-based
task force's they go state-by-state
asking for a license for music therapy
to date more than a half dozen states
have already adopted such a license and
the fact that these states have adopted
these licenses is not as a consequence
of some demonstrable need instead it is
because the music therapists have
mounted this campaign and there is no
better example than here in Georgia
Georgia in recent years adopted its own
music therapy license bill and the bills
adoption was classic bottlenecking
upon introduction georgia bill senate
414 went to a committee they had a
hearing at which time the only people to
testify on behalf of this bill in
support were music therapists both from
the national and the state organization
legislators are seemed a packet of
information in which they had letters of
support from other music therapists
letters of support from consumers from a
professor from georgia college who was a
faculty member in music therapy at no
time did anyone testify against the bill
at no time was any empirical evidence
ever introduced demonstrating a
significant threat to public health and
safety and at no time did a single
legislature or anyone else ask a
challenging question or express any
skepticism about the bill and now if you
want to work as a music therapist in
georgia you will do the following you
will earn a bachelor's degree or higher
from an approved program and the program
has to be approved by the music
therapist association the same people to
lobby for the bill you will pass a
national examination that's offer
only by the music therapists you'll pay
more than $300 for that privilege
you will complete 1200 hours of clinical
internship and you will have to be 18
years of age or older you'll pay fees to
the state of course and you will pass a
criminal background check and research
on occupational licensing that we and
others have done indicate that as a
result consumers in Georgia will now pay
as much as fifteen percent more for
their music therapy services but they
will not necessarily enjoy greater
quality of service or protection for the
public and if it's some later date the
legislature were to tried to reform the
music therapy license they will be
overrun by licensed music therapists but
they'll now be joined by members of the
state music therapy board who are also
seeking to protect their license now
often those of us who advocate for the
reform of occupational licensing we do
so by making economic arguments and chip
and I do that in the book but this is
more than just an issue of economic
growth this is also an issue of creating
a just society a society that is built
in part on preserving the right to earn
an honest living free from unnecessary
government regulation friends there's
nothing just about telling someone he
may not work in the occupation of his
choice or for which he is best suited
simply because it introduces too much
competition for someone else who is more
politically savvy in 1787 James Madison
wrote that the protection of property
rights is the first object of government
and for Madison property rights extended
to more than just real estate or to
personal property as we think of it from
Madison property rights covered quote
everything to which a man may attach a
value and have a right including
opinions in the free communication of
them and the free use of his faculties
and free choice of the objects on which
to employ them
Madison's disdain for the co-optation of
govern
meant for one group of citizens at the
expense of another was unequivocal as
was his inclusion of economic liberty
under the rubric of property rights
here's what Madison said quote that is
not a just government nor is property
secured under it where the property
which a man has and his personal safety
and personal liberty is violated by
seizures of one class of citizens for
the service of the rest where arbitrary
restrictions exemptions and monopolies
deny to part of its citizens that free
use of their faculties and the free
choice of their occupations which not
only constitute their property in the
gentle general sense of the word but the
means of acquiring property strictly
so-called in condemning quote arbitrary
seizures of one class of citizens for
the service of the rest or arbitrary
restrictions exemptions and monopolies
Madison could have been talking about
occupational licensing today and
bottleneck errs today so to fulfill
Madison's call for a just government to
execute the first object of government
elected officials today should work to
protect property rights including the
right of free occupational practice and
those of us who love Liberty we should
prod legislators toward reforming
occupational licensing and we should
support the work of those who seek to
break open bottlenecks and expand
economic Liberty our book talks about
bottlenecking and various different
occupations but we also tell the story
of courageous men and women who have
worked to break open bottlenecks in
their industry not just for themselves
but also for millions of other people
like them that they represent and for 25
years we've had the privilege of doing
that to represent such individuals along
the way so with that I'm going to stop
and we want to open it up for questions
and discussion as well and remember we
have a microphone that needs to be used
I Ryan come Georgia Secretary of State I
was gonna ask you what you've seen
around the country as a result of the
Supreme Court decision with FTC in the
North Carolina Dental Board and what I
know we've taken measures here that I
certainly supported that I think will be
helpful but what are you seeing
other states doing as a result of that
case so it's a little early to say yet
the case is fairly recent and so States
I think a lot of states are still in a
in a position where they're trying to
figure out exactly what they need to do
so my colleague Lee McGrath at the
Institute for justice has been spending
a lot of time going to various different
states and helping them understand
number one what's the case about what
are the implications and what might you
do as a result but in general I think
states are looking to create systems
that create much more oversight over
licensing boards this is the the nub of
it but these occupational licensing
boards for decades have been operating
without any oversight and so
consequently as we described in the book
the behavior is is essentially monopoly
behavior its anti-competitive behavior
and they've been able to do so because
no one has really paid much attention to
what they've been doing so now I think
in general states are looking at how can
we create systems of more oversight of
these activities but it's too early to
say exactly what form many of them are
taking
thank you take eater Lauer the alcohol
wholesale business that in georgia's
seems to have a lock hold on everything
is that common across the country and
are there any successful initiatives to
break that stranglehold that the
wholesalers have anywhere in our book
and in fact that's where in part where
the name of the book comes from so the
word bottleneck draws on not only that
just general metaphor but also the
context of alcohol distributorships so
it is very common across the country and
the wholesalers are a very powerful
special interest so efforts to break
open that particular bottleneck probably
the best example is one of our cases on
direct shipping of wine where we were
able to open up the market for direct
shipping of wine before that it was
basically illegal in most states so
that's probably the most pronounced win
that we've had other efforts I think
have been in the area around micro brews
micro breweries that have operated under
pretty strict restrictions all these
years and so the popularity of micro
brews have started to open up that
market and to allow more access and more
shipping and and a more direct consumer
access essentially cutting the
distributor out between the producer and
the consumer and so micro brews is where
we've started to see most of the
movement in there but it's it's very
small winds along the way so far
you're part of higher education it
appears to me a lot of this licensing
requires you to go to college or so
which is may well be just a total waste
of money at my opinion we have too many
people in college so just the first one
first and that is the issue of the role
of education higher education in
licensing there is no question that
higher education makes an enormous
amount of money off of Licensing it's
huge
in cosmetology alone when you look at
cosmetology programs around the country
we're talking about women young women
some men but mostly young women who will
go to school and they will pay tens of
thousands of dollars to earn a license
and the schools are earning an enormous
amount of money off of those
requirements and they know it
so license bill licensing bills that are
created will often have testified on
their behalf professors from
universities or students from university
students are sometimes bust down to
legislative committee hearings in order
to testify on behalf of a bill or
against a reform effort so higher
education does make an enormous amount
of money so here's a quick anecdote on
that sews every year we had a study come
out here Benita described it called
license to work it came out in 2012 and
we examine the licensing requirements of
a hundred and two low to moderate-income
occupations across the country the
report came out I received an invitation
to go to a policy consortium of higher
education leaders and to talk about the
study they invited me to go so I said of
course they asked me to prepare 15
minutes and I said of course I prepared
15 minutes to the second so I went to
this policy consortium there are several
hundred people there I was on a panel as
my turn I started to give my
presentation and you'll not be surprised
to learn that my presentation expressed
skepticism about licensing
so about halfway through my presentation
the person who invited me came down to
the front and stood in front of me
wanting me to stop and I thought well
you son of a gun you invited me and you
asked me for 15 minutes and you're gonna
get 15 minutes so I just kept going and
afterward the questions there was a
panel of people afterward the questions
were all to me and they were incredibly
hostile because they recognized the
threat of that message that we ought to
reform occupational licensing so yes
higher education does make an enormous
amount of money off of it unfortunately
the research on that topic has yet to be
done I think in a very helpful way so
hopefully we in the near future will do
some research on that to quantify just
the extent of their involvement
Sir David Martin Georgia Council on
economic education like most things I
can see a continuum here between
appropriate and inappropriate do you
have some examples where it s
appropriate to have strong licensure let
me answer it this way actually for too
many years we have lived in a binary
world of occupational licensing there is
either no licensing or full licensing
but that's actually not correct we don't
live in the binary world of regulation
of occupations in fact there is a menu
of regulatory options that can be used
and people don't realize this this is
something again my colleague Lee McGrath
is hoping that more people come to
realise a colleague of mine in the
University of Michigan we co-authored an
article and regulation magazine just a
few months ago looking at this
regulatory menu of regulatory options so
the way we describe it is to say think
of an inverted pyramid at the top of the
pyramid is market regulation because
there's yet another myth that is without
licensing there's no regulation
in fact there is regulation the market
regulates what does that mean it means
that as a as a somebody who provides
goods and services I'm being regulated
by my reputation in essence and by
consumers behavior so today consumers
have the ability unlike at any time in
history to influence what happens within
good the markets for goods and services
on your phone you now have more
information about goods and services
providers than at any time in history
and has more information than any
licensing scheme will ever introduce so
there is regulation its regulation
through the market but then as you go
down through the pyramid there are
layers of other types of regulations at
the bottom is licensing full licensing
in between those are various different
types of regulations that do not
necessarily impose upon the free
practice of an occupation so voluntary
certification for instance from a
third-party organization bonding and
insurance registration certification
through the government or another
organization these are different forms
of regulation that can be introduced
short of full licensing and the
advantage is they can create the same
benefits of licensing without imposing
upon free practice so what we say then
is first figure out what is the need to
be addressed through regulation is the
need to overcome asymmetric asymetrical
information for instance is the need to
make sure you know where somebody is so
you can access them to bring some
litigation against them what is the need
for regulation and then match up the
regulation to the need so an answer to
your question we would say there are
examples in between licensing and no
licensing or market regulation where
there may be some demonstrable need
here's one example
Florida obviously deals with hurricanes
on a fairly regular basis and so they
have an interest in protecting consumers
against fly-by-night contractors who
will come into the state and they may do
shoddy or or dangerous work and so the
state has an interest in helping
consumers be able to contact or be able
to know where these people are who are
these people where can I access them and
so registration accomplishes that need
it meets that need without full
licensing so there may be examples of a
need that needs to be met and we can
match up regulation with that short of
occupational licensing sir good I look
at this in a very general way most of us
need to have a license to drive drive an
automobile now the real public benefit
comes from requiring us to have
insurance liability insurance or some
sort of ability if we do damage to be
compensated now so my general question
is why don't we simply require that
there be insurance in providing a
service and forget about the regulation
allowing the insurance company to decide
whether that person is qualified that is
one of the options in our menu of
regulatory options so what's the need to
be met right going back to what I just
said what's the need to be met think of
the tree-trimming business what we care
about is protecting consumers from some
damage I have a tree that needs to be
trimmed I hire a company they come in
they sawed off this limb and it falls on
your car the externality problem
so how can we fix that we don't need a
full license to protect against that we
need to make sure that the company has a
way to make you whole because of your
damage so bonding or insurance can meet
that need we don't need to restrict
entry into the occupation we need to
make we need to make sure that we're
going to protect you against your loss
so in our in our menu that is in fact
one of the options so we advocate for
that rather than full Licensing when the
need is the externality problem one last
question
we unfortunately run out of time one of
the arguments we hear not just Public
Health and Safety
but is reimbursement just like it's a
medical issue like music musical therapy
we've heard this say we need the license
or we can't get reimbursed from
insurance companies or Medicaid what do
you say to that yes so there is a way to
address that without full license and so
this has come up on a number of
occasions that we've heard from
practitioners in various different
states the first thing we say is
actually check that premise don't take
it on face value so as an example in
Indiana there were a certain group of
therapists that had gone to the state
and they said we need a license for the
reason that you have just described well
we looked into it and they said by the
way the Affordable Care Act creates this
regulation the regulations under the ACA
tell say that we have to have a license
to be reimbursed so we thought well this
is crazy we must know we have to find
out if this is true so we went and
looked and what we discovered was it
doesn't actually say that it says that
if you're going to be reimbursed in to
the CMS you have to be recognized by
your state with whatever the state
requires so if your state says you must
have a license then you have to have a
license but if your state says you don't
need any regulation or the regulation is
something less than a license that's all
you need so the first thing is to check
the premise but then after that if it's
in fact true then what we say is there's
a way to create a form of special
recognition that does not restrict the
free flow of workers into an occupation
so if you want to
be reimbursed you want to enter into
contracts with the government for
instance or you want to be reimbursed
through the CMS as an example then we'll
create a special recognition a specialty
license just for those people so that if
you're the type of person that wants to
do that that contractor be reimbursed
you would have to earn this wreck the
special recognition but only if you want
to be engaged in that type of
circumstance everyone else can still
freely enter the occupation it's only
those who want to be reimbursed or enter
into special contracts so a special
recognition can be created just for them
without restricting free flow all right
thank you thank you very much dick
carpenter and the Institute for justice
for all the great work that you do we
really admire your work and we use it
here in Georgia hopefully we can be
successful in getting some of these
policy advances approved in the near
future keep an eye on Georgia policy org
for announcements for next month's event
we'll see you next month we are
adjourned
[Applause]
book TV is on Twitter and Facebook and
we want to hear from you tweet us
twitter.com slash book TV or post a
comment on our Facebook page
facebook.com slash book TV I'm a
historian of the United States in the
20th century I'm a historian of the
south like anybody of that description I
knew that Carolyn Bryant hadn't said a
mumbling word since 1955 and most of the
time nobody's been able to find her
she's been pursued by journalists and
scholars all through that time sometimes
we don't know hadn't known if she was
alive or dead so I allowed us how I
might be able to find time in my
schedule to talk to her my intention was
because I was working on another book
and I'd been working on it for a while I
can't even remember what it's about
my intention was to interview her put
the interview in the archive southern
historical collection where I thought it
ought to be and some historian in the
future would be would bless my name but
I had no intention of writing a book
about Emmett Till I had already written
a book about a a brutal murder a shil
murder that was rooted in that old the
old ghosts of race and sexuality you
know the black beast rapist versus pure
white Southern womanhood the fairest
flower of the land you know I knew about
that stuff I'd also written a book Radio
Free Dixie's set in the 1950s so this
was familiar territory I knew the story
pretty well I thought so but I went to
the library to to do a little research
just to prepare for the interview and
what I found was amid all the novels and
poems and ballads and songs and memoirs
there was one one book of history about
the Till case it was thin it was flimsy
it was very lightly researched and it
was 25 years old which surprised me a
little bit now of course we teach this
in all the american heck history
textbooks you can usually find a
paragraph on the Emmett Till case those
stories fundamentally go back to the the
two of the men who killed him at till
after they were acquitted after they
could no longer be retried a reporter
for Look magazine largest circulation
magazine in the United States gave them
several thousand dollars to tell their
story but of course they had to tell
that they killed Emmett Till
or they wouldn't get the money and
everybody knew they killed him until
anyway and they were all scot-free so
they told that and they told their story
everybody figured I think historians for
a while figured that if if he's two guys
admitted to killing a fourteen-year-old
boy that everything else they said must
be true too but everything else they
said was a lie
including Andy and but I mean it was all
a lie there's not a true sentence in it
right they were covering up for their
relatives family friends and others you
can watch this and other programs online
at book tv.org
here's a look at some books that are
being published this week Camille Paglia
shares her thoughts on gender equality
in free women free men in the Benedict
option
Rhodri r senior editor at the american
conservative provides christians with a
blueprint for living their faith in a
modern world Vanderbilt Law School
professor Ganesh seeder Amin warns of
the threat economic inequality poses to
democracy in the crisis of the middle
class Constitution former New York Times
Asia correspondent howard French
describes her